most likely to choose to walk instead of
using a cart one I think we're both card
players for sure I'm not gonna walk
either but there's just no chance Travis
would go home most likely to load up on
snacks at the time definitely big on
snacks Travis they're free give me three
and then I usually just throw them in my
golf bag for the next round who's most
likely to have the best handicap Pat's
definitely got the better handicap right
now but uh mine's is getting a little
lower as we speak it looks like we spend
hours at the ring me for sure he
definitely gets to the course way before
me I'm usually parking lot First Tee
most likely to get path by the crew
behind you me for sure you slow at
everything he does Pat it's ridiculous
how fast that guy freaking plays golf
and most likely to talk while their
partner is seeing all this Travis he's
known to hog a horn or two during a
swing
me for sure that is probably not